this is the Blue Lagoon geothermal spa
one of iceland's greatest tourist
magnets more than 600,000 visitors come
here every year but owner about is
Christian's daughter like many of her
countrymen and women doesn't come here
often that's because Iceland offers
countless other hot springs and baths
that aren't listed in the travel guides
to introduce us to the Icelandic hot
spring culture forty-one-year-old owner
takes us on a mini expedition bathing in
the springs is almost a daily ritual for
her and it's an old tradition on the
island
I mean like for for some nation they
meet at the bar or go to I don't know
sing about
big space here I would say it's the
swimming pool
that's the place where you meet our
first stop is the capital Reykjavik
right next to the airport is the city
beach where owner spends most of her
lunch breaks the water is 38 degrees
Celsius 100 degrees Fahrenheit to cool
off she heads to the frigid Atlantic
which is about 11 degrees Celsius all
the sites in your body wake up
about 300,000 people come to the city
beach every year but in the fall and
winter only the bravest dare take a dip
in the Atlantic think people do it
regularly like they never seem to get
sick or anything so I think it's very
good for your immune system and yeah
good for your skin also now we're
heading further inland a two-hour drive
southeast of the capital is a run along
thermal baths
a small cottage is the only sign the
hidden hotspring exists the two pools
have room for about 15 people the water
temperature is a piping hot 35 degrees
so nice feeling to be in here especially
when it's cold outside and then you dip
in and then in the beginning you think
it might be too hot weather you could
use it so so fast and it's so
comfortable another 40 minute drive away
and Erna takes us to an afternoon break
in the town of quarter garden what's
special about this place the restaurant
cured of kunst where chef alluringly
Renison cooks all the food with
geothermal steam in earlier times even
bread was baked this way
it tastes come from the fools because
basically when you are cooking with the
border never think that latter case
going to the water you know in the cook
in the oven you will lose it in the
Javier but in this stage there late in
the afternoon we had for sale Yvonne
alert it's a hot spring not far from the
eye of shot you lucrative volcano the
journey to the spring leads right by a
glacier after 15 minutes of walking
owner can finally dive in the spa was
built in nineteen twenty-three and is
one of the most beautiful on the island
earner even has her own relaxation kit
her special swimming cap and floats for
her legs allow her to drift effortlessly
through the water
so you take a pillow with you into your
hot spring and heck take a almost like a
nap you know you're not falling asleep
but you're getting this really quality
moments and rests in the evening burners
journey ends right where it began at the
Blue Lagoon the water gets its blue
color from algae and from minerals like
silica and sulfur it's said to be good
for the skin something that
distinguishes it from most other hot
springs in Iceland it feels very good
you it's warm and good and it's like
bathing and milk I would imagine yeah
owner takes her time relaxing in the
Blue Lagoon the entrance fee is a steep
40 euros while most hot springs and
thermal spas on the island are free